oh my god breaking new developments in
the long time conservatorship battle uh
between britney spears and her father
jamie britney spears is free
for all of you who have been out there
wanting that to happen it looks like the
judge has just ended this longtime
conservatorship after a nearly 14-year
battle with her father jeff paul is on
this story live for us from los angeles
hi jeff
yeah this has been a long time coming
this started several months ago we
started coming to these hearings here in
downtown l.a little by little britney
spears and her team essentially chipping
away at this conservatorship well now it
is all over she's been under
this strict conservatorship for 13 plus
years and it is now dissolved both for
her personal life and her financial
aspects of her life involving her money
and you could probably hear in the
background some of the excitement from
the hundreds of free britney folks who
have been out here throughout the summer
they sort of brought this to attention
shortly after britney spears said she
was going to go on a hiatus in 2019.
they began asking questions looking into
this conservatorship there was then a
documentary and that sort of brought
this movement
nationwide and then britney spears the
the pivotal moment i would say in this
is involves britney spears getting her
own attorney to represent her interests
and that's when she publicly stated for
the first time in a court setting that
she found this conservatorship abusive
and that she wanted out she wanted her
freedom so now she has exactly that one
quick note though there will be a cpa
involved in her financial
position
temporarily as she kind of gets back on
her feet but as it goes britney spears
is free
[Applause]
thanks jeff thank you very much
greg what do you think well i don't care
i absolutely don't care but i'm going to
put it i'm going to
this is why you were on t what you get
paid on tv you have to pretend to care
so i'm i'm deeply concerned about this
and i'll tell you why how does anybody
know anything about what's going on her
life other than her family and yet you
have this movement based on watching a
documentary and all these people
how much time do you have in your life
to protest over
somebody who doesn't even know you exist
and their conservatorship and you're out
there protesting shouldn't you be
spending time with your family shouldn't
you be worried about what's going on in
your town or what how your grandma's
doing not what brittany's up to so
this movement has the intellectual depth
of a kiddie pool but like i said i
really don't care i think she has
serious mental issues and her family was
probably dealing with that but nobody
cares because they're the bad guy so but
i still don't care
jesse do you care i do because as a
feminist martha it's too long that men
in this country have been allowed to
institutionalize women lobotomize women
and then force them into
conservatorships and then live off of
their earnings and i'm glad that this
very very effective lawyer swooped in
and
took away this gross arrangement between
this other bottom feeder attorney that
who was kind of in a conspiracy with
the father's attorneys to put her in
this legal straight jacket for so long
is she the most
balanced person of course not
have you seen the rest of the country i
mean the rest of the country is crazy
too
she should be allowed to be just as
crazy that's beautiful just hopeful i
never get a forced phlebotomy
really that didn't happen yeah you went
back as far as francis farmer to talk
about exactly
it's an impressive historical track
um
i grew up a huge brittany fan i was not
part of the free brittany movement um
but i just had other things to do i had
a few other things but i was keeping
track of her and
her vega show was great my sister went a
couple times but
what i do think is interesting about
this case obviously it changed when the
first documentary came out um but the
detail that seemed to have sparked so
much controversy was that her father and
her team were not allowing her to take
out her iud to make her own decision
about whether she was going to try to
get pregnant with her long-time partner
this and i think that that really
galvanized a level of support from women
and from a lot of men who were like what
how is this possible that this is uh
going on today you know in the post
lobotomy
but meanwhile she's doing all these
concerts and she's supporting all of
these people exactly you know that was
always my take i just thought you know
she's obviously running a business she's
employed all these people she's making
all of this money to support all of
these and they're mismanaging her money
and they're mismanaging her money so i i
think she's not running she wasn't
running a business number one and number
two that iud statement was questionable
right yes it was very questionable
because in conservatorships out in
california they do not it is your right
to get pregnant and to get married and
so
again i agree with greg on this number
one she has a fortune walking out of
this because she was in a
conservatorship for so many years into
the tens of millions of dollars it is a
very complicated situation i have
watched all the documentaries multiple
times i have read everything imaginable
about it and i can say that new york
times documentary that launched all this
they were interviewing her fans
that was the depth of their reporting
they didn't talk any they st they did no
reporting on her ment
alleged potential mental illness the
coverage of this story and the coverage
of violence in this country and the
coverage of the mental health crisis
does no one any service because it never
talks about illness and treatment and
and what might happen in a family's life
if somebody is suffering whether it's
schizophrenia or schizoaffective
disorder or bipolar and i think that
this has been junk journalism from
moment one well i think i've been proven
correctly